I see libraries playing a huge role in
these days bigger than they have I hope
and I knew it in the the US we've been
trying to make a kind of Federation of
libraries that because in our country
there that's one other very few networks
that goes from the biggest cities to the
smallest ones there's always a library
even in a little tiny town so we've been
trying to initiate discussions in our
libraries um our problem is that often
in increasing so we're not allowed to
discuss certain things that are
considered partisan so I had a question
I said what can these what if all of the
libraries in the US take a topic like
let's say freedom of speech would that
be considered partisan and they said yes
so we can't do that I said you can't
discuss freedom of speech and I said no
it's considered partisan because it's
considered challenging and this is the
new era that we're in in which
information is becoming politicized so
it's a very very tough moment and even
more important that we find ways to
cooperate with institutions of that deal
with information and culture best
example libraries to help people
understand what's going on in our
country in the u.s. we don't you know
it's very hard to distinguish now
between what's called fake news and real
news for example this morning in the
news
in the US and CNN there was a I
meteorologist think he's the weatherman
he tells you hey here's a big storm
coming in very big storm so there there
was a somebody asking him questions
about the big hurricane Harvey and
Houston in Texas that is now turning
into a flood and the guy who was asking
the question said what did this is this
a trend bigger storms we see a I think
we see a trend now for these mega storms
is that true and the weather the guy
who's doing the weather the
climatologist says I can't discuss
statistics so everybody here's you know
because now we have no more Department
of Energy where we're not taking we're
not keeping track of statistics anymore
because that's considered partisan so
the role of libraries is fill in it in a
culture in which information is
challenged and considered political as
it is in the United States with the
climate so that even a weatherman can't
answer a question that says are we
having more frequent storms is it I
can't discuss statistics so in order to
understand any kind of shift in climate
let's say it's getting cold or hot or
whatever you need to keep a record of it
and you need to like look it you need to
have a a yeah yeah you need to have a
record of trends and of a factual record
of trends so and and real numbers so
that then is no longer being kept in the
United States as many of these
departments are being
cancelled and closed so we have
libraries and so we have to find a way
to keep these conversations going and
and for us in the u.s. it's very
important that we be able to maybe
cooperate with other libraries that can
maybe help us let's say that's my answer
you